foreign
that the final ratification for
finland's membership seemed to be in the
pipeline within these days I hope
it is important at the same time to
underline that our NATO membership will
only be complete when Sweden also joins
the alliance today we're you know we're
really excited to work with future
allies at the four Finnish Effigy teams
that have landed here have been
conducting planning with our crews as
part of that exercise that we'll also
see U.S French Netherlands and Estonian
aircraft but the message today really is
about three things first of all
interoperability learning how to do more
together
I'm also the cohesion cohesion among
allies partners and so on and finally
deterrence and our commitment jointly to
defend Estonia to defend NATO and to
defend Europe
the capabilities of the Finnish Air
Force do not need elaboration and we are
looking forward to welcome
Finland as a NATO Ally in the very near
future and hopefully the swedes also
before Vilnius
[Applause]
thank you